what's up guys Colin here obviously I'm
in Berlin for the starladder major and
you know what it's been an incredible
competition so far but one of the
highlights of this whole trip was
getting to speak and sit down with g2s
own Ocelot the founder of that eSports
work at g2s headquarters here in Berlin
now we talked about a lot of incredible
[ __ ] g2 eSports csgo team the future of
eSports and how far is too far when it
comes to G Tuesday social media memes
but obviously when I was at the
headquarters I forgot to record a
[ __ ] intro so that's what this is
hope you enjoy
[Music]
we're here in Berlin there's a reason
that I'm here and that's the starladder
major unfortunately g2 is not going to
participate in that top eight but they
did do really well they made a nice run
of it and they almost made it how are
you feeling about the csgo team right
now it feels bad from the point of view
of the expectation from everybody that
players ourselves the fans but I don't
know who it's with majors man g2 is like
I think majors like where we
underperform the most and it's like in
the last six seven eight majors in g2
it's always being like two three or like
some fucked-up results like that on the
other hand I'm actually I can't be
prouder of the work of the team we've
seen them work here in the office
Malek is doing an insane job like you
know structuring processes and adding
organization to to an otherwise somewhat
chaotic meta and and I do enjoy watching
a lot of counter strike these days as a
result but but you know it which means
also that you gotta hate heads you know
if you want to qualify to these things
you better be on point on that on the
d-day and that's I think what didn't
happen
tell me honestly tell me bluntly with
teams like Australis Team Liquid with
players like zai woo and simple running
around there is this g2 a number one
team I think our current setup and
lineup everything can happen you can be
number one but I don't think
realistically we can be number one I
don't I don't believe so we have players
that have been legends in the past we
have players that can be legends in the
future
when I look at a manic people don't
understand how smart this guy is about
the game and how much he plays and when
I look at Jax
neck's is 25 I think it's 25 right he
has the biggest balls I've seen a player
half like his entry fragging as if he
was entry fragging for the last 15 years
in the top five teams like I always have
a saying which is that you recognize a
good player by crunch time you know yeah
when Cranston comes you recognize
whether a player is good or not and when
crunch time comes he's a [ __ ] beast I
think that we do have potential stars of
the future and I do see Jax as that
potential guy the way he comes across
you know super open and then [ __ ]
goes around dancing and it's like it's
like you know it's a guy that you can
clearly see doesn't give a [ __ ] he just
wants to
fun and you know make it big and and
that's the kind of player that can make
it big I think you give these two
players time they can be the stars of
the future Kenny it does show signs of
tighten times the inconsistency is there
indeed but the work ethic he's been
pulling through in the last couple of
months three months and the love for the
game that he's regained as a result of
you know a manic coming in and as a
result of just seeing the game with
different eyes yeah again you know has
revitalized his love for the game and
sharks is always a staple you know who
they expect shocks to be the number one
player in the world tomorrow I can tell
it's possible but maybe not because he's
you know he's been playing the game for
a long long time it may be true that
when it comes down to cross her
placement aim tracking stuff like that
the new guys will eventually take over
out aim them yeah of course the likes of
simple the likes of seaward that I just
you know just love the game so much and
play the game so much he fixed the poem
a single time and he's got
[Applause]
they just hit heads all the time and
more and more of those will keep coming
there's there's so many of these guys
that are just are just hungry to hit
heads and they just will always hit
better heads than the older guys yeah
yeah but the older guys bring something
different - right exactly and that's a
beauty of conical you can have both and
you should have both I mean it's good to
hear because obviously as a
counter-strike fan you know really adore
the likes of Kenny s and shocks you know
we love them no matter what and we want
to see them succeed but I just want to
move move away from CS a little bit
because my favorite thing about g2 has
nothing to do with how successful you
are in CS or siege or League or anything
in CS
like in CS don't say a computer sex will
no comparison successful as per our
standards at least that's fair enough
you're not you're not meeting your
standards yeah yeah every other game I
mean yes yeah but I what I do what I do
love about you guys is your personality
as an Oregon your vibe and how that
comes across especially on social media
cuz that's obviously how like that's how
up the personality of an org if there is
such a thing and I think that there is
can reach people you guys are [ __ ]
Savage is like it's every day I wake up
and I see some [ __ ] and I'm just like
dude like you're gonna make somebody cry
with it that's crazy
when did you just when did you decide
like og - we're gonna be dank as [ __ ]
like that's good yeah so we actually
made a brand exercise some time ago like
a year and a half ago and I remember
walking people through what I believe
should be our character since forever I
always treated my job when I when I was
a player as if I was a gladiator and at
the same time as if I was a musician or
a performer more than a football player
you know I'm comparing but I'm more
entertaining than competitive but I'm
very competitive insanely competitive
but very I think I'm more entertaining
you know I always look to get that smile
or get that goose bump from people you
know and and so eventually we came to
the conclusion that we wanted g2 to be a
character you know when you look at the
samurai you have to know what the
samurai stands for and there's no other
brand in these words that you can say
that
maybe hundred thieves you're like yo
dope you know you can listen to the
music and you're just I just imagine the
hundred thieves guy just walking around
the street listening to Drake and you oh
my god from the hood you know I I get
that you know I get that is a is a
consistent brand attribute for us the
way I am vision our samurai he's just
walking cocky as [ __ ] but he's a nice
guy he has the heart in a nice place you
know walking around saying how's it
going yo how's it going all the all the
ladies are turning their heads and the
boys are turning their heads we look
like we smell good
we have fun always have something
positive and fun to say preacher time we
go out and party and have fun partying
that characters a winner you know he's
always there in crunch time like if
you've got cela comes to kill the city
he'll appear and he'll [ __ ] Godzilla up
okay no and we will do it while having
fun okay and at the same time he will
meet his antihero yeah and he doesn't
hate him he'll make fun of him okay and
then he'll be the sheered of him
and he will do it while smiling and
having fun so that's our character and
that's how we try to come across us
every single post every single video
every single everything we do we try to
represent that samurai and the g2 army
which represents all the samurais in one
and I am in your dojo right now and
that's pretty cool um the reason that
this personality that you're talking
about is so interesting is that until a
few years ago every eSports org was so
serious oh my god they're better players
and yeah well yeah the [ __ ] same
yours is everywhere I wish I wish you
know I wish you to follow me and and and
hope I have good games and that was the
most we ever got and then one day they
go for your support we are devastated oh
my god yeah we just got into this game
please give them a follow what the [ __ ]
is that man and then one and one day
double if does something like Oh
everyone else's trash or he throws a
jersey on the garbage which is nuts it's
honestly not that big of a deal right
but people flip out yeah you know and
you guys come along and you're not the
only ones doing it obviously but you're
you're a legacy sports or you've been
around for
and you guys come along and you just
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I mean if you look at our office we try
to have as much fun as possible when you
see it what is he on Twitter is what you
see between our interactions we tell
each other to [ __ ] off with while
smiling it's a very open have fun type
of culture and I think that's why we
thrive while at the same time if things
go wrong yeah we hold ourselves to the
highest possible standards so if one of
our videos is a 7 out of 10 quickly a
meeting with 12 people in the opposite
we talk about from the content team to
discuss why the content piece was an
attender of them let me ask you what
what is actually a 7 out of 10 video
versus 10 is it do you want know what
what I always say is okay our 7 out of
10 is a 10 out of 10 for fanatic oh
that's this you know okay a senator of
10 for us is 10 out of 10 from liquid we
have to be a 9 out of 10 minimum yeah
bare bare minimum for YouTube now we're
talking about content right in 2019
I feel like an eSports org is more of a
content house or at least that's one way
to go we look at like the some of the
orgs other ores that people are buzzing
about right 100 thieves obviously faze
clan they're doing vlogs they're turning
out we want to do and you guys have that
personality but you are so firmly rooted
in competitive eSports can you talk to
me about just the balance of G 2 in
terms of competitive and and content and
where you see you guys going in the
future so competition is a tool for us
to entertain hmm and if we win we know
we can entertain better than if we lose
at the end of day everything was down to
entertaining we may not always have the
best teams in the world every game but
we will always be up there in the top
you know yeah and we will win
tournaments here and there all times
that's gonna be the case for the next
decades the beauty of this is that many
teams are very different you know like
you have the lifestyle type of brand
that is heritage right it's more like it
and I'm gonna over exaggerate things
just for the purpose of conversation but
it's like more like the adidas or stuff
like that right whereas we are more like
the Disney and then there is fnatic for
example is a very product heavy company
so fnatic will be more like Microsoft
with some
you know lifestyle brand attributes and
there's Tim leak with a lot of service
you know Timmy liquid you know the
service business a lot of agency work so
these companies are all very different
from each other you know and I like that
yeah and what I we have taken this niche
we are under two entertainment company
and we look at our job as you know we
should be on Netflix with a couple of
shows we have the making the squad show
that is a bit like an x-factor type of
show like a talent show do we think
about entertaining at large and and not
just competition
faze clan and huntys which is more like
lifestyle it's you know their founders
are so large yeah in you know as
creators they can just do it like this
with the camera you know yeah big for
half an hour
yeah and that's gonna get them eight
hundred thousand clicks yeah abuse it
isn't that isn't that like the way to go
though because like okay I don't think
there's a single way to go it's not
adding order but I think will succeed
okay with the product stuff Tim liquid
with succeed with their agency business
YouTube will succeed with their
entertainment kind of approach and
hundred people who succeed with their
you know thinking about lifestyle and
thinking about apparel type of thing
yeah okay I think all of us have our
space our place you know I'm very
concerned and I have been from the
beginning about the model that utilizes
geolocation right oh yeah by the way I
think that's absolute like that's trash
and I speak with every single publisher
out there and I always tell them listen
the worst thing you can do is geolocate
this is not [ __ ] baseball you grow up
in in New York and then your grandfather
brings you to the Yankees game and then
you have this emotional attachment to a
physical location yes that you grow up
with even if you move to a different
state you grow up being a Yankees fan
because your grandfather brought you
there
here is [ __ ] it's not like that like I
never left Spain when I was 14 years old
and my biggest Idol was spawn Mohammed
spawn right from sk-gaming and he was
playing in the Danish tournament with a
Swedish team in a German organization
and I was watching online from Spain and
that was my idol right so things don't
work like that anymore I don't I don't
care whether the team that wins is
Spanish I really can't care less I mama
they will call me globalist
a citizen of the world you know and I
think the world's moving towards that
direction and I think [ __ ]
geo-locating is putting artificial walls
what this should be known is that you're
limiting my growth I'm a global brand we
have friends from China Taiwan Vietnam
North America you know both Canada and
the u.s. South America Spain Africa
literally everywhere in the world and
you want me to be called the Madrid
bears look exactly why why would you
partition all of those fans out why
would you say oh well you can be fans of
us but you're not a real fan because you
know we're greats
it's not honestly I can be wrong but but
I am very vocal and very assertive when
I have a very clear opinion yeah and
that's what I believe it's it's
interesting because you know when I ask
that question obviously my mind was
pointed towards Blizzard properties
right as you were talking I remember I
did all these interviews before LCS and
LSE franchise and a lot of the a lot of
the owners and stuff told me similar
ideas like well I asked you know how are
you gonna how are you gonna position
your brand how are you gonna get fans
like you're new to this or your
rebranding they said well we're gonna be
we're gonna be the British team or we're
gonna be messenger you know if you hear
that automatically I can picture you
what kind of person that is typically
they're American and they're like this
NFL star you know and and and chances
are they've worked for one of these
companies before yeah and they're like
okay so same rules apply is competition
people play against people well there
you go sports it makes sense to me well
it doesn't you know it really doesn't
like like people don't care like if the
state of Virginia having a team people
care less and less about that there will
be some people that care but could care
less and less about that you want to be
the future you want to be the past yeah
that's the question I would ask myself
to this publishers if you want to be the
future think creatively about ways to
make this a global sport and to reach
people from all across the world yeah
maybe you can you can geolocate
languages the élysée is doing that
perfectly and you can do all of that
stuff you can still invest money on
caring for those people that want to
hear the shoutcasting in the original
commentary but don't put those
artificial walls that should not exist
yeah but anyway simply watch for
affidavit for a interview I hope you
have a good weekend in you know spending
time with teams there yeah yeah it'll be
fun I'm looking forward to it thank you
so much for your time really appreciate
it yeah no problem man it's a pleasure
Cheers thanks for watching all right you
have not finished a video no still
record him get whispers the comm /up
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anyone else hit up
our Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]